he may have aliens and T2 under his
Bells but James Cameron has never even
attempted a third franchise movie is his
impossibly ambitious vision for Pandora
just a pipe dream the sequel to 2009
Smash Hit Avatar is back at long last
but fans of James Cameron's
record-breaking franchise have much more
to look forward to even after the way of
water Avatar 3 is already pretty much
locked in and James Cameron has many
plans in place for more Navi Thrills
this is why Avatar the way of water
doesn't matter quite as much as you
might expect from a massive end of the
year Blockbuster by a filmmaker of
Cameron's pedigree with a third movie in
the works the immediate future of the
series is already pretty clear
regardless of how the way of water pans
out because of this the Avatar movie you
should really be paying attention to is
the third one virtually everything about
the Avatar franchise will be riding on
the third installments which won't enjoy
the bumping curiosity from fans who have
waited over a decade to return to
Pandora
early Twitter Buzz around Avatar the way
of water has been largely positive and
why wouldn't it be Piranha 2 the
spawning notwithstanding James Cameron's
history is a genre sequel writer is
peerless hasta la vista baby though even
Cameron himself admits that the way of
water is a terrible business case one
that will need to become one of the most
successful movies in history just to
break even it's hard to bet against his
CV Avatar 3 however is where things will
get tricky Cameron is a great filmmaker
but is also kind of sporadic in fact the
way of Walter is his 21st directing
Credit in 44 years which includes
individual TV episodes documentaries and
short films while he's been a nine
variable success story in the director's
seat Cameron is an unproven Helmsman
when it comes to steering a franchise
beyond that first sequel sure he
produced Terminator dark fate but he is
never fully committed to a film
franchise after a sequel and certainly
not on the scale that Adam our demands
in other words cameras plan is to
venture far beyond familiar Waters
nevertheless the director has laid out
plans for multiple big budget sequels
that are all set in the same universe
something that's entirely Uncharted
Territory in his body of work and we
simply won't know whether he's capable
of doing this until Avatar 3 is released
let's be honest James Cameron could have
retired to a tropical island after
pretty much any of his umpteen Smash Hit
movies the fact that he is constantly
pushed on Embrace new technology and
focus on making even more impressive
films is Testament to his drive to
surpass himself since making a Sci-Fi
sequel this is bread and butter the way
of water is just one dazzling step in
his Avatar master plan but this idea
can't truly unfold until Avatar 3
spreads its wings as a filmmaker Cameron
certainly has the jobs to deliver
multiple epic sci-fi works and he's had
plenty of time to draft the stories he
wants to tell in this world but are
there enough enticing stories to tell on
Pandora or has Cameron become so
enamorous by his stylish world that he
fails to see there's not enough
substance for his multi-movie story arc
only Avatar 3 will tell considering
Cameron's tenacity especially when it
comes to the Avatar movies it's clear
that he views them as His biggest
boldest filmmaking move yet he has
chosen to commit himself to building a
mega franchise from scratch what greater
Legacy can that be than building an
entire beloved Universe with your own
two hands none of the major sci-fi
franchises on which Cameron has worked
have peaked past their first two movies
this creates Mighty expectations for
Avatar 3 which is the first Avatar movie
that forces Cameron beyond the
successful movie and its sequel
structure and into the franchise
territory he seems so Keen to explore
possibly the best point of comparison to
what Cameron seems to be trying to do is
fellow sci-fi franchise Chef George
Lucas hello there if Cameron manages to
expand his Universal way Lucas crafted
the original Star Wars Trilogy he might
very well turn Avatar into a multimedia
Powerhouse if this happens expect to see
pandora-centric movies and TV shows long
after Cameron is gone however if the
filmmaker gets lost in the style labor
substance mode of Lucas's prequel
trilogy his expensive experiments may
turn into a massive embarrassing failure
it's pretty impressive really after all
it's not every day that we see an
established Superstar filmmaker swinging
for the fences the way Cameron does with
the Avatar movies especially at this
relatively late stage of his career when
it comes to Cameron's own reputation as
a filmmaker Avatar 3 could well be his
best chance at a home run or an easy way
to strike out and then there's the money
James Cameron has said that he is fully
prepared to wrap Pandora up after Avatar
3. if the movies don't turn in a pretty
profit this financial aspect further
increases the third Avatar movie's
importance in the grand scheme of things
in a worst case scenario Avatar 3 will
not only be responsible for its own box
office it's also Pandora's last line of
defense if way of the waters numbers
disappoint there's a good chance that
will happen too her variety the way of
waters break-even point is somewhere in
the vicinity of two billion dollars for
comparison 2022's other major
long-gestating sequel the highly
successful top gun Maverick has made
1.48 billion dollars so far should the
way of War took Peak at such numbers and
assuming that Avatar 3 also comes with a
2 billion profit margin the movie would
need to make over 2 0.5 billion dollars
to break even and cover the way of water
slack to achieve this Avatar 3 would
have to become the third highest
grossing movie in history this
hypothetical scenario might seem like a
big ask but it's not unattainable at
least if your name is James Cameron the
movie that Avatar 3 would need to
surpass for that number three spot is
none other than Titanic which currently
sets at 2.2 billion dollars of course
topping the overall list of the original
Avatar which has raked in a cool 2.92
billion dollars over the years with the
September 2022 release alone boasting a
30 million Premiere weekend so if anyone
can make these absurd numbers work it's
James Cameron still it's likely that
even he'll be sweating for quite a while
seeing as Avatar was the embodiment of
slow and steady making a relatively
meager 77 million dollars during its
opening weekend and building from there
as such even if they're successful the
way of water and Avatar 3 may take a
long time to make their aliens will the
studio grow tired of this high stakes
gambling with achingly slow returns will
Avatar 3 need to make an immediate
colossal box office impact to reassure
everyone involved this may be yet
another reason to keep an eye on what
might turn out to be the most important
movie of Cameron's career
[Music]